♪ ♪ ♪
Dans les couloirs de l'Hôpital
Sainte-Justine résonnaient
aujourd'hui de belles notes.
Des musiciens de l'Orchestre
Symphonique de Montréal ont
interprété des airs du temps
plaisir des petits patients
et de nts.
- Si on vient à l'hôpital,
on vient en courant, on est
ça change comme ça, c'est bien.
- Tout à fait, en fait,
anxieuse puis finalement,
làvoyez, elle est déjà
un peu plus calme, donc ça
a tout de suite attiré
- Le concert de l'OSM à
-Justine est une tradition
de Noël. L'an dernier,
la pandémie avait empêchéais
cette année, même masqués,
les mules mules mules mules musr
des moments de réconfort et
de douceur.
C'était la première fois que
maestrestre lors d'un événement
de ce type, et pour lui, pas de
doutes, la musique peut aider
à guérir et à traverser
les épRAFAEL PAYARE, chef d'orc,
Orchestre symphonique Montréal
- Avec la musique on peut offrir
une petite pause, un petit
Vivaldi, Dvo ák , un petitcadeae
"Gracias, merci."
- Accompagné d'une douzaine de
concert au personnel et aux
bénévoles de l'hôpital. Une
pause bien méritée et appréciée.
clinicienne
- C'est très valorisant , puis
ça nous donne une motivation à
notre approche avec les enfants,
être chaleureux. Fait que ça,
c'est dee one one one one one on
dit souvent, c'est petites
attentions-là c'est notre paye
aussi, ça nous fait du bien.
- Sortir des traditionnelles
ts pour aller à
la rencontre
des gens est un rendez-vous
offrir la musique
eau.
MADELEINE CAREAU, cheffe de la
direction OSM fait
du bien, apporte de la sérénités
un endroit comme ici, je pense
quens en ont ns en ont ns en ons
musiciens aussi en ont besoin,
c'est très bon,
c'est stimulant pour eux aussi
de pene peut contribuer
à un peu de joie.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'espace d'un instant, le
public qui assistait au coine au
oublier ses soucis. Unis par
sique et
emportés par l'énergie
communicative de Maestro Payare,
transformés en chorale
improvisée.
♪ ♪ ♪
(chants de la foule)
Des notes de douceur àl'approche
des Fêtes pour dire merci et
pour rappeler aux enfants
seuls
dans l pour retrouver
la santé.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
♪ ♪ ♪
(applaudissement